[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
reggie miller called game seven between
the mavs and the suns he will be back at
it tomorrow it'll be game one of the
western conference finals between the
mavericks and the warriors and uh always
great to see the hall of famer reg it
was back in december i think where
you were talking about luca plodding and
saying he was probably the heaviest he's
ever been on the court luca has since
come back around to say you know what
basically you were right did luka ever
say anything to you uh since then in
between those comments and these
comments kind of saying yeah you were
right
he didn't per se say thank you he gave
me a dap and
shook his head and said i understood
more so jason kidd
jason kidd said thank you
um
because
it's almost and you know this very well
as a parent
you can say everything you want to your
kids
and it goes in one ear and out the other
but when they hear it from somewhere
else
and it's the same message they're like
oh okay i get it
so
um he understood and he knew
um and jason kidd had been kind of
verbalizing to him
you've got the kingdom at your feet
young man but you've got to get in
better shape and you've got to stay off
the officials
and he took both of those advices
coming from kevin harland and myself and
obviously from jason kidd
and this is where we are now
luca
was around 260 pounds which is 30 more
than his listed playing weight he said
people are going to talk about it yes or
no but i know i've got to do better i
had a long summer i think i relaxed a
little bit not taking care but i've got
to be better i had the olympics took
three weeks off i relaxed a little bit
maybe too much i just got back on track
and i remember when you tweeted or you
said it and i text you
and i said those are strong comments and
you said i think was i fair
and i said yes because you're assessing
what you're seeing
that luca was not the same player you
weren't making fun as much as you were
being an analyst in that situation and i
was curious if people were going to say
are you fat shaming luca in a situation
yeah obviously some people did but again
and that's the beauty of what you and i
do and especially for myself
uh you know having been on uh turner and
tnt for the last 15 plus year
they give us a platform for us to be
honest and i know how great luca can
and will be in the future
um and the start of the season
he wasn't at his best and for
all the reasons that you just
highlighted
words out of lucas mouth
um he understood it was a long and tough
summer for him too for them to qualify
for the olympics
it was very difficult and i understand
why he took three weeks to a month off
um
first of all i would like to know where
he was partying for three or four weeks
for him to pick up 30 pounds because
that's the kind of party
i want to go to with
i want to you lukas
out with you
um but he understood to be at this level
in the nba
he had to be better he had to be lighter
and again we weren't fat shaming because
when he is at his best which we have
seen in these playoffs
no one can touch him and it's funny
every time we would speak with jason
kidd before the games he he keeps going
back to he's lebron he's lebron he's too
big he's too physical they have no
answer for him and he's showing that
because of
when he's in shape and his size being
able to get wherever he wants on the
floor dan
help me understand this i brought this
up earlier that we look at the best
point guards of all time you know we'll
have chris paul in there and isaiah and
you have magic and john stockton and
steve now whoever's on your list
they're all short guys except for magic
right
why isn't lebron in there
as the
second best point guard of all time
where is luca
he's a point guard
why why aren't they designated point
guards here i think we're past that
stage now
in today's game because it's
positionless basketball now
um when you and i were coming up in the
70s 80s and 90s
there was you know point guards shooting
guards small forwards power forward
sinners
everything now is gumbo everything is
all mixed together
and
luca handles the basketball
85 90
of the time same with lebron
and you look at lebron's numbers he has
point guard
numbers in terms of assists i mean he's
up there with the point guard so
you're right
lebron luca at the end of the day
will have the same type of numbers as a
top
seven eight point guard but
you look at their body size being six
seven six eight six nine at times for
magic
um people kind of scratch their heads
because the whole notion of point guards
goes back to bob cousy yeah at six feet
you know people think of bob cousy as
the ultimate point guard john stockton
in isaiah
but that's no longer in today's game how
do you explain what happened to the
phoenix suns on sunday night and when
did you realize
they were going to be in trouble
every time out
kevin harlan and ourself we would look
at
one another like can you believe this is
like
we were in shock
and when luca set the tone early scored
the first eight
with two of them being two step back
threes
i knew
something magical was going to happen
that night
we thought it was going to be the
reverse we thought oh phoenix they're
going to put these kids to bed they're
tired of this
and they were
not two
they were really three steps behind the
dallas mavericks
but i'm gonna give credit to jason kidd
and his coaching staff
very well prepared all series but to me
lucas set the tone in game seven and
that's what your best player has to do
because he has to give
belief and hope to the rest of the guys
like okay jump on my shoulders it's
gonna be okay when he set the tone with
those first eight everyone fell in line
in formation and it was downhill for the
suns after that i don't know if you ever
felt this i'm sure that you made other
people feel this but when luca hit the
corner jumper
and the net had a zing to it like it
wasn't he just made it or kind of made
it it was whenever i would play against
somebody and they made a shot
it was how they made the shot that
sometimes stayed with me where are you
going oh damn they're on tonight and
when luca made that shot from the corner
i think the second three that he made i
went uh-oh
they're in trouble because he was
feeling it and letting the uh the crowd
know hey
you better buckle up we're in for a long
ride tonight
uh you know and when he was knocking
down those shots it was in front of
larry fitzgerald uh travis kelsey you
know it was celebrity row that was right
there and he was just giving it to them
not to them per se but to that general
area and every time he made a shot it
was like a a gasp was in the air
so
they knew
the phoenix sun's team knew
that he was coming for business and
sometimes when your best player he just
let the air out of that whole building
and it gave confidence and life to the
others on that map's team you know
spencer dinwiddie
was a no-show the first five games in
game six and seven he found his stroke
and that's because of the belief
that they all have in luca do you think
the window of opportunity for the sons
is closed
i don't think it's closed you don't win
64 games by accident um
i think they have some decisions to make
this summer number one being deandre
ayton which
you know for him to only play 17 minutes
in game seven
and then for monte to get on the podium
afterwards
and when asked that question why did he
only play 17 minutes
his only response was it's internal
something obviously and clearly was
going on behind the scenes
that we're not privy to
but again oh you didn't see anything on
the sidelines between those two
no and
that's the way they've always run their
organization you're not going to see
anyone get out of character whatever
happens with the phoenix suns is going
to happen behind closed doors
but it was a little surprising because
coming into this series
we felt and everyone felt that ayton had
to be the difference maker because he
was so dominant all season he was
dominant in that first round matchup
versus the pelicans and you would think
he would have the advantage because
basically they were playing five small
guys with you know bertons and maxie
cleaver being the tallest guys for the
mavericks at six nine he should have the
clear-cut advantage and after that 25
point first uh
first 25 point first game you didn't
hear from deandre ayton
so it was a little head scratching
um but they have some decisions to make
talking to reggie miller reggie will be
on the call game one western conference
finals mavs and the warriors that'll be
tomorrow night game one tonight heat and
the celtics who do you like
wow
i really feel this is a pick em series
um
i can make a case for both sides you
look at boston
what they've done in the first two
rounds and i know it was a sweep of
brooklyn but those were four very
hard fought games
versus the nets
and then to
defeat the defending champs in seven
having won twice in their building
it it says a lot um for boston my
question going forward do they have
enough
and every possession is going to mean
something in this boston miami series
because both teams are fabulous
defensively
and
no one is talking about how great jimmy
butler has been for the miami heat
in these playoffs i know everyone's
talking about luca and rightfully so and
jason tatum rightfully so you could put
jimmy butler's name in there as well
because he's been that good
if you're asking me to make a pick
i'm gonna roll with what my son told me
this morning when i posted them the same
question that you just asked me
who do you like he's like dad
i'm rolling with uncle jimmy in miami
heat i think i've no one's giving miami
heat a lot of love and i know tyler
hero's been disappointing in these
playoffs
but i just think something special is
brewing in south beach
i'm gonna go with jimmy butler in miami
in a very tough seven game series see i
think that tyler hero is the key to the
miami heat because if he's averaging
over 20 a game everybody else does what
they're supposed to do then i think
miami can win this if tyler hero
continues to give you six eight ten
points off the bench i just don't think
you can match the firepower there
uh all right with you 100 and he's got
to show up another big x factor will be
gabe vincent obviously he gets the start
tonight no kyle lowry we don't know if
lauren would be back at all in the
series you hope he would be
but gabe vincent is going to have to
play
above his means
um for the heat to be successful you
were mentioning the celebrities at the
phoenix suns game assigned from new york
with your interaction with spike lee
what celebrity on what team
no you noticed or you had interaction
with around the league
interaction with i would say
it was always cool to play the lakers
and obviously
shake hands with jack because he was the
spike lee
of the lakers and at the time in the
late 80s and 90s it was you know jack
nicholson the actor the academy
award-winning actor so it was kind of
cool for
him to just
acknowledge
your play
did he say anything
negative to you did he try to get under
your skin no no no no the only person
that ever tried to do that was you know
who from new york yeah um everyone else
for the most part celebrity wise because
i had already set the precedent in the
bar high if you're gonna talk to me
you're gonna be a part of the day
so they all knew what i did to spike so
they were so celebrities are always
somewhat on
they were on notice that i could go off
and i was going to make them a part of
the dialogue so they were pretty cool
with that did you ever think about
fighting spike lee no
it would it was never going to come what
if he was 6'5
then it's on
[Laughter]
that's my rule 6'5 or above okay it's on
six five or below
it's all it's going to be all about
words
but when you you you try to use that to
your advantage
like that's the key sometimes that
you know i always wondered and i always
thought maybe you got too into the
conversation with spike lee and that
could take you away from your game
whereas luca it felt like was
acknowledging the crowd a little too
much like stay in your game stay in the
moment how hard is that to do
it at times it could be difficult look
i'm going to be honest here as well
sometimes you have to manufacture your
own type of
i don't know
well jordan did this jordan would make
up feuds with guys who didn't even know
he had a feud against him sometimes you
gotta
[Laughter]
you gotta manufacture it you know you
gotta manufacture bad blood
and i think at times that's what luca we
see him doing all the talking to the
fans
i personally i like it you know it it
keeps you engaged
and
you know and then sometimes it it spills
over to your opponent because we saw him
and devin booker kind of going at it a
little bit
you've got to build that up in a series
because you're seeing these you're going
to be seeing each other for the next 10
to 12 days so i've got to build up bad
blood right now there's no bad blood
between the warriors and the mass but i
guarantee you after game one something
will be manufactured draymond green will
say something luca will say something
jaylen brunson's going to get into it
it's going to be a fun series to watch
how they manufacture the hate towards
one another
lakers still haven't named a head coach
and i'm
curious why not
maybe they're trying to exhaust their
their search uh i felt
that they were waiting for current
coaches that were still in the playoffs
yeah uh to take a look at is that a
desirable job reg
it at the end of the day it is the laker
brand
they do
them along with the celtics have the
most championships
desirable i don't know a lot of pressure
comes with that
and it depends on who you're going to be
answering to are you going to be able to
coach the way you want yeah or are you
going to be hearing from jeannie buss
kurt rambis rob palinka are you going to
be hearing from all these people
or are you going to be able to
execute your game plan on a nightly
basis the way you want and now phil
jackson's in the mix
in terms of voices right
and how much pressure is that especially
if you're one of these young coaches
that they've been interviewing and
potentially could get the higher
you know you've got phil jackson one of
the greatest of all time now he's
chiming in
so it's very difficult i doubt then you
look at the roster reg we haven't even
like you still got lebron james and you
still got anthony davis but other than
that you've got a lot of work to do and
you're going to have to make russell
westbrook
work
they're not going to trade him
you're going to have to make him work
somehow
and i you can't change him
yeah but there's ways where you can
tweak him hopefully to make him more
successful and on the flip side russell
has to look himself in the mirror too
and say i'm not the 23 year old russell
westbrook and from okc
right but
some of those shots are
like you don't even see that in a youth
league game he's sitting the side of the
backboard like he
i mean come on
sometimes you gotta look yourself in the
mirror dan he's gotta look himself in
the mirror and say what when he looks at
himself in the mirror
i'm not as good as i used to be but
but i'm also not as bad as theodore and
the dance and reggie miller are saying i
am as well i would never let him take a
jumper from
18 feet out 15 feet out like he can
shoot free throws and he's a good
free-throw shooter but i i just have to
say to him you you have a no-fly zone in
here
everything is going to be going to the
hoop there well here's the problem
that's not the type of player
that can play with lebron james lebron
james and anthony davis they need space
floor spacers
that's not russell wesley oh my god
and that's what the new coach is
probably saying right now oh my god i
know
okay is steve kerr underrated
or overrated
as a head coach yeah
well i certainly wouldn't say he's
overrated for a guy who's watching he
stepped into a great situation here
well
so did phil jackson
yeah
okay
in both places in chicago well no but no
he didn't
he stepped into that but then they got
scotty and they added some pieces there
and and doug collins didn't make them a
winner and he had mike so phil i'll give
him credit in chicago in la that felt
like hey i'm gonna show up on third base
let me tell you about the triple i hit
i would say steve kerr
as great as mark jackson is and was for
the warriors
steve kerr just added
a little bit more spice
to the warriors i don't think he gets
enough credit okay
i don't think he gets enough credit
right
as well as mark jackson i think people
tend to forget that mark jackson laid
the foundation
and it gets lost in the mix for what he
did for the warriors and with the
warriors yeah because mark made a they
were a defensive team like mark stress
defense it felt like kerr came in and
said let's open this up
let's
steph you're going to be taking those
shots i'm fine with that i mean it took
him a little while before he went
are you
i don't know if i want you shooting out
that far and then all of a sudden he's
like you keep shooting not that far yeah
go ahead
clay go on ahead you know no kerr added
the offensive identity and they kept
mark jackson's defensive
identity as well yeah
thank goodness
he added to it all right
he's reggie miller he'll be on the call
tomorrow night nine eastern on tnt game
one a western conference finals mavs and
the warriors reg looking great and uh
we'll be watching tomorrow night
theodore you're the best danettes love
y'all that's reggie miller reggie miller
if we win a sport when we win a sports
emmy reggie gets a sports emmy